where is the weirdest place you've
acupuncture I've never been in a room
where someone's passed out and someone's
been like does anyone hear no
acupuncture where's the red one I'm
so that you're we're not doing Ren one I
mean that is aggressive that is the
gooch
you're not that's take your puncture
there was a patient that was willing to
allow us to needle run one for
educational purposes I think this person
was a little like I'll let you guys do
it if you want to I would hate it as
he's just sitting like um and they were
like you want to come see no thanks I'm
good people so you were around people
who got the taint needle
I'll tell you the red one is a
misleading term that's really putting a
shine on some honestly
[Music]